هذا ما تبقى من المنزل المحترف في منطقه
تل الزعتر بمخيم جباليا شمال قطاع غزه
اصبح اثرا بعد عين قطع متناثره متفحمه
الاسقف تشققت وتساقطت منها اجزاء كبيره
هذه واحده من الغرف بطبيعه الحال نحن بشق
الانفس استطعنا ان نصل الى هنا ويحاولون
ابعادنا من المكان لخطورته حقيقه الامر
ولكن حسب المعلومات التي تتردد حتى الان
اخر احصائيه تقول ان هناك همم 21 شخص هم
افراد وسكان هذا البيت في الطابق الرابع
من هذا المنزل اصبحوا ما بين قتيل وجريح
في المستشفى وما زالت فرق الدفاع المدني
والاجهزه الامنيه تقوم بعمليات التحقيقات
لحصر الاسباب والملابسات والتداعيات
لمعرفه السبب نسوان كان هناك احاديث تتحدث
عن وجود بعض همم
المقتنيات من البنزين والمواد المشتعله
خلال عمليه احتفال في هذا المنزل هو الذي
ساعد في عمليه الاحتراق لكن هناك اسباب
عديده حتى الان همم الاجهزه الامنيه هنا
تقول بانها ما تزال فتحت تحقيقا وسوف تكمل
هذا التحقيق تمهيدا للاعلان عن نتائجه همم
في الساعات القادمه وائل الدحدوح الجزيره
تل الزعترلي